Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier
and welcome to The Pedestrian--
I...
Oh-ooh!
F...?
Huuuuuh?
F. I'm F-ing! I'm F-ing as hard as I caaaan!
WUT OHH OHH
OHH OHH
OHH OHH F
WAH-- F, IM F!!
IM ALL..IM ALL KINDS OF F
Hahh?
[Mark Screams]
I don't know what to do
Oh? Aaahhh
[Mark Breathes in loudly]
Oh?!? Ooohh!
F-- (inhales deeply) oh F, okay GOT IT!
WOAH--
Okay so what happens if I move this out of the way and-
Aaaalmost  there...
Waaait... wh-
A-almost-- right THERE!
No-- okay. How 'bout I just do this?
Ha-booski!
Uh-dedudedudedede
Whoa!
That's cool!
Whaaat? That's so cool!
What the heck?!
Whoa! This is freakin' awesome!
Whaaaaat...
Okay, so-- alright, hang on a second everybody, I--
I had no idea what this game was about.
When I saw the game I saw a very limited window into the game.
This is beyond anything that I'd known before!
I had no idea that this was the game!
I am just delighted, 'cause it's something so new!
That I've never seen before.
This is a puzzle platformer that I-I've never known...
I-I've never known!
I-I've no idea!
Okay, I'm gonna stop freaking out about it and I'm gonna
TRY to get this generally in order here.
So, what I need to do now--
I need to break this connection and I just need to connect this to here.
(Softly) Whaaat?
What? OOOH, wait a minute. No, I can't do that.
So what I need to do is break this connection,
put this here, no-- AAAAAH!
I need to go here, and then I need to go here!
OH!! My brain hurts!
Oh! But that's-- oh, that's not neato-burrito.
Wait-- okay, so if you break that connection it-it sends you back to the beginning.
So you have to figure out a way to do it without that.
So if you go through here,
close this and break this you get sent back to the beginning.
Yeah, lemme try this way again because--
Unless I'm mist- Oh, you can!
OOOH okay so you just need to press down to be able to go through that.
Oh, that's puzzling. OH, that's pa-duzzling. Oooh Yes.
Thank you for the tutorial!
But I think I got this one.
There we go, there we go-- oh, neat!
Oh, that is--
Okay, the reason I'm freakin' out about this, and I don't mean to freak out too much about this
because this is a cool concept, but I wanna be very--
very, very sure about what I'm doing before I have to do it.
But it's just a concept that is, in fact, new and interesting.
I have never seen anything like this.
This is like a mixture of Portal, and--
Gosh, numerous of-other things, possibly, but--
Like, just th-the concept of mixing and matching the levels
while you're ALSO in a different world--
Like, outside of these pedestrian signs, which is kind of the concept of this.
(Whispering) It's just really freakin' cool.
And I really freakin' like it!
But either way, I need to be smart about this.
I need to go here, drop through there, to here...
And then go up through there.
And that's what I need to do.
And th-and th-the idea that you can do it in whatever configuration that you want is also...
just super darn interesting! And unique.
And that's the thing that I love about this!
Is-- th-that's so unique!
And I almost missed this completely,
because I barely saw where I was going.
Where am I?
And also "where am I?"! That's so interesting, the fact that I'm in a warehouse,
and I'm a guy on a sign!
The depth of it is just really intriguing to me.
To see how deep we actually go here.
Oh... we need to get the key, and also to do a lever
and also to throw a box.
And that's really cool, the way tutorials are done!
And the happy-go-lucky music of it!
It all combines to a really interesting experience.
But that's the last that I'm gonna freak out about this,
because now I'm pro'lly gonna have to use my brain about this.
But obviously, I'm gonna tell you even before I even get through this game
You can play this for yourself.
There's a link down in the description below.
Play it, it's freakin' awesome. I like it a lot.
You guys can't do--
so you gotta kinda think of it like, completely outside the box, because--
I don't need to go in there first, I can't go in there first.
I have to go through...
here first, right there.
Get that key, go through this door, go over here,
through this door, unlock that, and then climb my way out up here.
It's like, it's a really interesting way of looking at it through an overview
while also planning inside for what they are.
And I can't wait to see what other concepts are gonna come through this!
Where am I going?!
That's delightful!
Oh, where am I now?
Yeah, see I need to get a key before I'm even through here.
So I gotta find a way to get up there,
but that ladder is too high up for me to do that,
so I gotta go down it.
So I gotta go... down through the ladder, first--
No, this one first.
So I gotta go down...
then through there... but how do I do that?
'Cause I gotta get the key...
but I'm not gonna be able to do... that.
Hmm. That's a puzzle.
So I can only go through the door on the left,
I can't quite reach the door above me,
so I'm gonna have to go down through the ladder first
Oooh, I think I know.
I gotta find the limit with which this'll reach--
Yeah, like that! Oh, my god!
That's awesome. That's awesome!
Down we go, and through there and up above, oooh my god my brain hurts!(Now you're thinking with portals!)
And then I can just drop down through here and go through there and-- in.
OH! It's so delightful!
(whispering) It's so delightful.
Where am I going now?
Oh, is there like a dark secret to this?
As to why there's a freakin' dude--
Oh my god, blades.
What is that??
What IS that?
(whispering) I have no idea.
Aw, it's so cool.
What's in the background there playing on the screen?
I mean, kinda what it reminds me of is the environment of Stanley Parable
without the narrator dragging dow-dragging you down to Hell. ( yesh, mark )
But oh, it's the story of two people meeting!
Are they gonna go on a date and fall in love forever?
Power of imagination, I suppose. ( sure )
And this pedestrian guy being closed in a box forever and unable to escape.
Oh, yes. Oh, so much yes.
Okay wait, before I do anything, lemme get an overview.
Hooo! Whoa, nelly!
Okay, so the only thing that I can do is connect this ladder to this...
I wonder if anybody walking by this warehouse just suddenly freak out
at the fact that the pedestrian signs are thinking for themselves.
I don't know, but if they are... oh well!
There we go. Alright, got it.
Hup! Alright. Jump, jump...
*gibberish* Hippedeh-hoppedeh-hibbeduh.
Grab that, get through there, go down there.
Uppidy-up.
Yeah, you actually have to plan through the whole thing before you're actually done
or else you're gonna get stuck and dead.
herdeded herderderderdle ( are you OK mark?
Okay.
skedettledoodle
Ugh... I wonder how they even came up with this concept.
Like the concept of a pedestrian sign being able to move through its own world.
And also being able to go through all these different worlds.
And somehow, when I'm moving through these places,
it's not automatically taking me there, I have to manually walk through.
So literally, my guy is going through tunnels...
in like a fourth-dimensional bullshit area of this entire universe
and traveling through the thing.
But to what end? I wanna know!
I wanna know why, and I wanna know for what reason but we're gonna find out!
What is that-? OOOH!!
The lever controls that, that goes there,
whatever the hell's over there on the right, it's... somethin' or other.
Ooooh, now we're getting a lotta pieces here and my brain startin' to kerfuckle.(wtf mark)
Alright, so-- there's two ladder points, one is there,
one is definitely on the exit. So I'm assuming this is gonna be the last one because...
it needs to be... at the end of it.
And that's an elevator that's gonna take me up and down.
So when I come outta here...
I got-- this has gotta connect to this, apparently.
Maybe.
'Kay, so that's gonna connect to that...
Lemme make that relatively easy. Even.
To be pleasing to the eyes.
Eh-- oh, boy--
Yee-ah-- okay there we go.
Alright, so start there, go...
*concentrating*
Through there and then back-- now that's gonna be interesting.
Maybe this can just be an add-on room over here
that you have to go to...
Like, eventually.
Alright, I'm gonna move it all. Just 'cause...
I like having the ability to have this all where I need it to be.
Smooth!
That's the-- that's the other thing, I was trying to think of the right word.
You're doing your own level design...
I mean, the level is designed the way it is, and it's supposed to be that way
but it's also...
Y-y-you're like an amateur level designer here!
And you gotta think about the intricacies of the level--
Ooooh, no--
You gotta think about the intricacies of the level itself
while also getting you out of the way.
Oh, I really hope it keeps up with the puzzle elements
because if there's good stuff continuing all the way through this,
then this could be the potential to something really, like legitimately incredible here.
Because there is just--
oodles, and skedoodles of potential here.
Okay, so I need an "up" to go to this "down",
but that "down" needs to go to the "up",
so I gotta hit this room before I hit that room,
I gotta start here...
Okay, so this is gonna go for a key, which is gonna go there...
but I don't need to go there yet, I can go through there...
later, so this is next, this is after...
So this is next...
Then we'll go up here.
So that connects there, that connects there...
Okay, so we're gonna criss-cross a bit,
we're gonna criss over here, we're gonna cross over here...
Stretch this a bit farther,
just for logical reasoning's sake.
Okay, I think that's gonna be it!
riIIGHT?
RIIIGHT?? Okay, here we go.
Ha-booski! Alright, got my key.
herdede burp burp
Ah, so delightful.
WHEEE-HOO! Oh my god that was far.
Hep! Hop! Yup! Okay.
And-- no, my ride!!
Alright, don't squish me...
And there we go!
Oooh, I'm tickled to death! I'm tickled!!
I gotta stop being tickled-- eegh.
Is there death over there? Oh, just a spring.
Holy shit, awesome.
That's a cool way of doing it, because it's introducing new concep--
(gasps)
OOOH NO!!
Oh no, it's so good! Oh, it's so good!!
Oh it's such a good idea! I love it...
Oh, I'm so gonna support this!
I'm gonna support this right now-- I don't think I have a Kickstarter account--
Oh man, this is such a good idea.
I REALLY hope this Kickstarter is still goin'.
Skookum-Arts. Okay.
The Pedestrian. A GREAT idea.
GREAT idea. GRRRREAT idea.
FAN-TASTIC idea.
Okay, so-- they are Greenlit,
I'm assuming that Kickstarter was successful
because this was Greenlit a while ago.
And there hasn't been an update yet, BUT this is a great idea.
I legitimately hope that this goes somewhere because this is such a unique and interesting concept--
The-the level design of it,
the aspects of the intricacies of the background of the level and also the level that you're in.
Like, it all combines into a very pleasant experience
and I think there's so much potential here. (music begins)
So either way, that is The Pedestrian,
let me know what you think of this and you can play this demo for yourself
right down in the description.
Please, I wanna hear your feedback on this one,
because this game is (whispering) super cool.
So thank you everybody so much for watching
and as always, I will see you-- in the next video!
BUH-BYE!
(outro music) MiniMusicMan - Crazy La Paint